[Música]
[Aplausos]
es un par de semanas me hicieron una
entrevista en la tele
y me llamaron un rato antes para
maquillarme
y la maquilladora margarita que me había
visto en vídeos anteriores me pregunta
de qué signo sos
positivo le digo
provocándole un poco dale no te hagas el
vivo me dice seguro que sabes cuál es tu
signo
y porque quiere saber mi signo del
pregunto provocando la de vuelta
porque los signos dicen mucho de las
personas me dice pero vos o científicos
así que seguro que no cree en la
astrología
y porque te crees que los científicos no
creemos la astrología de diego
la verdad no sé muy bien me dice
porque la astrología tiene mucho de
ciencia
no solo es ciencia lo que se aprende en
la facultad de medicina es mucha
arrogancia entre los científicos que
descalifican a la astrología sin saber
que es una ciencia distinta de la que
aprendiste vos
tener razón margaritas con aulas de la
arrogancia de los científicos que son
bastante egoístas
pero la ciencia como empresa colectiva
es una gran humildad
con mecanismos de
control del fraude y de la deshonestidad
académica y hay una ciencia quiero decir
la ciencia como juego
con sus reglas
y así como hay un fútbol y hay un tenis
hay una ciencia
se le podría llamar ajedrez al fútbol
pero messi no va a estar muy de acuerdo
más aún margarita le digo
yo creo que la astrología
no está de acuerdo con ciertos rasgos y
ciertas reglas que definen el
conocimiento científico como cuál es
una diferencia importante es te digo
en la actitud que tiene la comunidad
científica respecto de su disciplina
comparada con la comunidad de astrólogos
la astrología no fue revisando su teoría
a medida que se fue incorporando
conocimiento nuevo y a medida que fueron
apareciendo problemas irresueltos dentro
de la teoría del momento
la astrología es indiferente a los
acertijos y se resiste al compararse con
teorías alternativas le digo
y cuáles no tiene alternativa para vos
más bien no
la psicología por ejemplo no te parece
posible
que mi personalidad está determinada por
mi genética o propia entorno más que por
una estrella lejana cuya luz veo hoy
pero que ni siquiera existía cuando yo
nací
más aún hay estadísticas en poblaciones
grandes sobre todo en el hemisferio
norte que muestran rasgos distintos
según el día de nacimiento por ejemplo
los de libra
suelen ser un poco más equilibrados que
el resto
eso es por las constelaciones
o porque es el final de la cosecha y
mejores nutrientes y todavía nos llegó
las enfermedades invernales todo apunta
a lo segundo
o los nacidos en septiembre también al
hemisferio norte en promedio suelen ser
más exitosos
es porque son de virgo
o porque el periodo escolar en el
hemisferio norte empieza en septiembre
los nacidos en ese mes suelen ser los
más grandes de la clase tienen más
confianza en sí mismo siempre medio
tienen un mejor desarrollo cognitivo
pero alberto
la astrología tiene ecuaciones o
científico que tendría que interesar
sí es cierto qué
la física usa la matemática y
misteriosamente las matemáticas es la
descripción es el lenguaje para
describir las regularidades del mundo
pero no todo lo que es matemático y
científico yo podría decorar una torta
con ecuaciones y eso lo convierte una
torta científica
o puedo usar algoritmo sofisticado para
la cábala
como para ganar el casino
la matemática es un lenguaje y en todo
el lenguaje se pueden decir disparates
en la física lo que hacemos es comparar
una teoría con la evidencia y si la
predicción no está de acuerdo con la
evidencia revisamos la teoría es decir
la física es vulnerable a que se la
pruebe incorrecta
y más o menos me mira con cada margarita
en ese pero la luna
tiene un efecto sobre las mareas o no
y nosotros somos agua o sea que algún
efecto tiene que haber sobre nosotros
es cierto hay un efecto pero
cuantitativamente insignificante le digo
si tengo en cuenta el tamaño de la luna
y la distancia que está de la tierra
el efecto gravitatorio sobre mí cuando
la luna cruza el cielo es el mismo
efecto gravitatorio del obelisco cuando
cruzó el 9 de julio
el número del mismo
y con los planetas estudian más chicos
efecto
y esos efectos no son tenidos en cuenta
por los astrólogos
no es tan así me dice margarita porque
hay muchos astros los 80 por ahí vuelo
que tenéis que hacer es ver el vídeo el
fulano de tal que es un campo
su tipo muy reconocido entonces agarré
el celular y empecé a bajar el vídeo del
capo
y mientras tanto ella me julio
y vio que sabían así el 15 de febrero
acuario no tienes que ser me dice
pero sabes que no soy de actuar yo en
realidad dinero como
los días no duran lo mismo que las
noches eso se debe a la inclinación del
eje de giro de la tierra sobre sí misma
respecto del plano de giro de la órbita
de la tierra alrededor del sol
sin esa inclinación
los días durarían lo mismo de las noches
no había estaciones
ahora aún con esa inclinación hay dos
días especiales durante el año donde esa
aguja está perpendicular a la línea que
une la tierra con el sol esos son los
equinoccios los dos únicos días del año
en los que el día dura lo mismo que la
noche equinox
en tiempos de ptolomeo
en el equinoccio de marzo del otro lado
del sol
estaba la constelación de aries y ese
era el punto cero del zodiaco
ahora resulta que esa aguja invisible
que apunta hacia la estrella polar no
está estrictamente fija sino que por
sutiles razones gravitatorias describe
un cono
y la punta de ese cono
completa un círculo en unos 20 mil años
26 mil años eso quiere decir que cada
dos mil años
el equinoccio se desplaza a 30 grados
que equivale un mes
o sea que en realidad ahora los que
nacieron el 21 de marzo no son de arias
sino que son de piscis
y yo que nací en febrero no soy de
acuario sino que soy de capricornio
y le dio todavía más
si dos personas nacen en el mismo lugar
el mismo día ya la misma hora pero una
al año siguiente de la otra difieren en
su coordenada cósmica en 35.000 km s que
no hay una unicidad
entre el momento de nacimiento y la
posición de las estrellas
margarida no se mostró interesada
entonces
yo empecé a ver el vídeo del capo
me llamó la atención el uso de
información basado en evidencia el tipo
dice
el universo existe hace 15 mil millones
de años hay miles de millones de
galaxias el universo se expande
esa es información reciente que forma
parte de la revisión de la visión
científica del mundo que no modificó la
visión astrológico
y eso es un punto crucial en las
pseudociencias el uso de información
científica actual para validar
una visión antigua ya descartada por la
visión científica del mundo
en otro momento el capo dice
que todo está conectado con todo
importando o contrabandeando una idea de
la física cuántica
una de las contribuciones fundamentales
de la física cuántica es la
indistinguible lidad de las partículas
entonces por qué discriminar entre un
átomo de una estrella lejana y un átomo
de un objeto que nos rodea
porque la astrología se apoya en la idea
aristotélica de que somos el punto focal
del universo
y de que el mundo celestial en su pureza
cósmica es distinto del mundo terreno
hecho de fuego de tierra de aire y de
agua
pero hoy sabemos que eso no es así todo
está hecho de átomos
un átomo de carbono de una estrella
lejana es idéntico a un átomo de carbono
de mi piel
y de un hato de carbón o de una roca en
marte y de un átomo de carbono de la
carcasa de plástico de un
electrodoméstico de la cocina
es decir que la influencia que puede
tener sobre mi destino un átomo del
anillo de saturno es el mismo que puede
tener la licuadora de mi abuela
de modo que si tenemos en cuenta la
interconexión total
yo sólo no tendría saturno en siete sino
que tendrías lavarropas en aries
y lo digo en serio
más aún hoy sabemos que no somos el
único sistema planetario
hay otros planetas
con estrellas
y somos el cielo de esos planetas
y así como ellos hipotéticamente
determinan nuestro destino nosotros
determinamos el suyo
marca recta me dice
pero no hay fe en la ciencia me dice
y en el fondo me estaba haciendo un
planteo sutil
porque nosotros en ciencias aceptamos
sin demostración
que las matemáticas son el lenguaje que
describen la regularidad del universo o
sea que le dije en parte si ves me dice
tener razón
pero no es una fe en el sentido bíblico
de hebreos 11 1 que dice que la fe es la
evidencia de lo invisible
a medida que la ciencia fue indagando en
la anatomía del cosmos
la ciencia fue haciendo visible un
esqueleto causal mucho más rico y mucho
más complejo
del que postula la astrología y gracias
a ese conocimiento
hoy tenemos satélites vacunas contra la
polio celulares luz eléctrica anestesia
contra el dolor de muela
es decir
la astrología
en el fondo tampoco pretende ser un
sistema basado en la fe sino que más
bien es una fe disfrazada de ciencia
si soy de acuario soy creativo
ahí estás usando una relación causa y
efecto
o es prácticamente imposible que una
luna en libra se abra completamente su
ascendente en escorpio a partir de los
dos años y medio
sin dónde sale el fundamento de una
frase como esa que la tomé literal de un
congreso de astrología
para mí está basada en una idea en
cierto punto soberbia
de que el universo está pendiente de mi
existencia y de mi psiquis
cuando en realidad cada avance de la
ciencia enfatiza nuestra humildad en el
cosmos
no tengo nada de especial soy apenas un
ser más de una especie más en un planeta
más en la vastedad de un cosmos que ves
y al que le soy completamente
indiferente
esa es la elección de la astronomía
que en un principio estaba empatada con
la astrología pero de la que fue
gradualmente diferenciándose
despojándose de los dioses y del
pensamiento mágico
pero no porque no es la magia en la
realidad
la magia de ayer es la tecnología del
presente
sabes que creo margarita edición
que yo creo que en parte la
responsabilidad está en un sistema
educativo que instala la idea de una
ciencia como algo férreo frío e
irrevocable que en lugar de acercarnos
nos aleja de la poesía de la realidad
la ciencia es esa minería de precisión
de los misterios del mundo que nos
enriquece el asombro nos conecta
y nos unifica
la dicha de entender puede ser
profundamente espiritual de garita
pero alberto a mí la astrología me
sirvió
te entiendo perfectamente margarita
a mí por ejemplo la música me sirve como
un lenguaje que toca mis emociones pero
yo un preludio de bach y no le puedo
pedir que me cubre una hernia de disco
en cambio cuando estoy eufórico o
melancólico o triste un preludio de bach
me da una paz y un alivio tan grande por
eso te entiendo que puedas usar la
astrología para resignificar el pasado
o para aliviar angustias del porvenir
que no puedes entender todo pero
margaritas yo te pido personalmente no
uses la astrología para cosas en las que
no se aplica
la astrología no nos va a ayudar a
encontrar la nueva fuente de energía
renovable o para hacer un puente
por eso no la uses para determinar la
fecha de operación de apéndice o
decisiones importantes de tu vida por
favor no la uses para eso
me miró con cierta aprobación mientras
sacaba el delantal porque ya tenía aquí
la entrevista
y yo sentí que habíamos llegado al punto
de convergencia
nos saludamos amablemente me fui
caminando por el pasillo y cuando iba
caminando siento que me dice alberto
vos tenés la luna en leo te lo apuesto
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]